berlin verbietet demo gegen korona
regeln die veranstalter wollen nun vor
gericht ziehen
mini kompromiss statt großer wurf die
wahlrechtsreform von union und spd stößt
auf kritik
und vom hotspot zum musterschüler
italien scheint die korona pandemie
besser im griff zu haben als viele
andere länder
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara vinken abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
an meiner seite ist für den sport wieder
norbert lehmann deutsche wunder von mir
hohe wellen schlägt das verbot der demos
gegen korona regeln am samstag in berlin
die veranstalter wollen es juristisch
anfechten und trotzdem demonstrieren
der berliner innensenator warnt vor
enormen gewaltpotenzial und kündigt ein
großes polizeiaufgebot an
als begründung des verbots verweist die
behörde auf eine ähnliche
großdemonstration am ersten august dort
hätten sich demonstranten bewusst über
hygiene regeln und auflagen
hinweggesetzt
eine abwägung also zwischen dem
infektionsschutz und dem grundrecht auf
versammlungsfreiheit sylvia bleßmann
berichtet aus berlin techno runs
gegenüber dem corona virus war teil der
berliner demo vor drei wochen keine
maske kein abstand die hygiene auflagen
seien bewusst ignoriert worden so die
einschätzung des berliner innensenators
versammlungsfreiheit bedeutet ja nicht
bewusst gegen geltendes recht verstoßen
zu dürfen
deshalb ist diese entscheidung der
berliner versammlungsbehörde keine
entscheidung gegen das versammlungsrecht
sondern eine entscheidung für den
infektionsschutz konsequentes vorgehen
der polizei könig der senator an
er sei nicht bereit ein zweites mal
hinzunehmen dass berlin als bühne für
corona leugne reichs bürger und
rechtsextreme missbraucht werde
der anmelder der demonstration michael
berg zeigt sich in einer
pressemitteilung schockiert und
befürchtet nun dass grundrechte nicht
nur temporär eingeschränkt werden sollen
dagegen wie man sich wehren
wer infos verwaltungsgericht gehen wir
werden natürlich auch in zweifel das
bundesverfassungsgericht anruf
ein breites bündnis von corona gegnern
hat er zu einem fest und einem
mehrtägigen camp nach berlin gerufen
auch die afg wollte wieder mit
marschieren das kann nicht sein dass
eine demonstration abgesagt weil er dazu
rechtsbrüchen kommen könnte sondern
recht im gesetz sind auf einer
demonstration durchzusetzen
das zu den angekündigten corona demos in
berlin auch ein breites rechtsnationale
spektrum mobilisiert belegen recherchen
der mobilen beratungsstelle gegen rechts
wir beobachten mit großer sorge
bundesweite mobilisierung im
rechtsextremen gewalt affinen
gewaltbereiten spektrum dabei mehren
sich im internet die aufforderungen
trotz verbot in die hauptstadt zu fahren
und zu protestieren
felix zimmermann ist hier aus unserer
rechts redaktion felix die
versammlungsfreiheit ist ein hohes gut
in unserem rechtsstaat ist dieses verbot
aus juristischer sicht wasserdicht also
die versammlungsfreiheit steht im
grundgesetz im grundgesetz steht aber
auch dass sie beschränkt werden kann so
ein verbot muss aber immer
verhältnismäßig sein
konkret muss es zum beispiel nicht
möglich sein durch auflagen hier die
gesundheitsgefahr abzuwenden solche
auflagen gab es ja das letzte mal im
mund und nasenschutz sollte getragen
werden mindestabstände beachtet werden
und sie wurden missachtet die auflagen
von daher ist es durchaus juristisch
vertretbar dieses verbot zu verhängen
auch wenn es gute gegenargumente gibt
die veranstalter sagen ja die verstöße
gegen infektionsschutz seien nur
vorgeschoben ist eigentlich eine
politische entscheidung könnten sie
damit vor gericht erfolg haben
politische entscheidung wir haben ja in
letzter zeit gesehen dass sehr viele
krone proteste stattfinden konnten
das heißt diese behauptung der start
wurde meinung unterdrücken die es
eigentlich abwegig in dem fall hat nun
aber leider so aus sicht des
innensenators herr geisel gesagt er
wolle
corona leugner keine bühne bieten und so
eine aussage ist natürlich wasser auf
die mühlen der protestler
sie können sagen seht her es geht wohl
doch darum und die meinung zu verbieten
der start der darf aber versammlungen
nicht verbieten mit dem argument dass in
die dort vertretenen meinungen nicht
passen
da muss er neutral
ob das jetzt das gericht verwerten wird
es war nur eine lieben bemerken von
einer geisel bleibt abzuwarten denn das
argument gesundheitsschutz das ist ja
nach wie vor nicht von der hand zu
weisen
dankeschön für diese information lange
felix zimmermann
die bundesregierung nimmt noch mal viel
geld in die hand um corona hilfen zu
verlängern und familien zu allen
entlasten im ersten koalitionsausschuss
nach der sommerpause haben sich union
und spd unter anderem darauf geeinigt
das kurzarbeitergeld zu verlängern
allein das könnte etwa zehn milliarden
euro kosten schätzt der finanzminister
anton kurschilgen fasst die beschlüsse
zusammen unternehmen sollen jobs in der
korona krise länger durch kurzarbeit
absichern können bisher waren zwölf
monate möglich jetzt bis zu 24 solange
beträgt das kurzarbeitergeld weiterhin
bis zu 87 prozent des nettolohns auch
die überbrückungshilfen für kleine und
mittlere unternehmen sollen verlängert
werden bis ende des jahres eigentlich
war das programm befristet bis ende
august
gesetzlich versicherte die kranke kinder
zu hause betreuen sollen länger
kinderkrankengeld bekommen elternpaaren
stehen dann in diesem jahr jeweils fünf
zusätzliche tage zur verfügung
alleinerziehende bekommen zehn weitere
tage
wer corona bedingt angehörige pflegt
soll bis zu 20 arbeitstage frei nehmen
können
und es gibt noch weitere corona hilfen
auf die sich die koalition geeinigt hat
in unsere zdf heute app haben wir sie
zusammengestellt von einer
bildungsoffensive bis zur grundsicherung
für künstler und dann gab es noch eine
überraschende einigung im
koalitionsausschuss beim umstrittenen
thema wahlrechtsreform
das problem ist seit jahren bekannt der
bundestag wird immer größer und damit
immer teurer
598 abgeordnete soll er eigentlich haben
709 sind es aktuell und die sorge war
dass es nächstes jahr nochmal mehr
werden könnten wie nach langem streit
jetzt der kompromiss aussieht berichtet
david gebracht
schon als zu beginn der
legislaturperiode über 700 stühle hier
verschraubt wurden war klar der größte
bundestag aller zeiten muss kleiner
werden
nach drei jahren zank über die
wahlrechtsreform die alle wollen nur
jeder anders verkündet die große
koalition einen kleinen kompromiss
danach soll zum 20 21
mit einer entsprechenden dämpfungs
maßnahme dem ungehinderten aufwachsen
des deutschen bundestages sozusagen
entgegengetreten werden es gibt
begrenzungs mechanismen dafür sorgen
dass der nächste deutsche bundestag
wahrscheinlich kleiner sein wird als der
jetzige
die koalition will das ab 2021 unter
anderem drei sogenannte überhangmandate
nicht mehr durch ausgleichsmandate für
die übrigen parteien ausgeglichen werden
wenn erwartet so etwa zehn mandate
einsparen zu können was die koalition
beim thema wahlrecht als kompromiss
vorgelegt hat ist wie man bei uns im
norden sagt eine reine wähler phase
wieder einmal ist ein verschiebebahnhof
aufgemacht worden die gefahr eines xxl
bundestages ist nicht gebannt
denn die liegt wesentlich an der zahl
der wahlkreise
doch die bleibt vorerst unangetastet
erst 2025 soll dann eine große reform
greifen von derzeit 2 199 soll die zahl
der wahlkreise auf 280 verringert werden
eine kommission soll zudem weitere
reformschritte ausarbeiten
vor der wahl im nächsten jahr ändert
sich erst mal nur wenig theo koll in
berlin was bringt diese reform erst mal
herzlich wenig die position lagen auch
einfach zu weit auseinander wobei das
heute beide koalitionen seiten sich
schöngerechnet haben als hätten sie
unterschiedliche rechner hatten gelernt
nach meinem verständnis dürfte auf jeden
fall die union leicht profitieren weil
sie fast alle überhangmandate holt und
drei davon jetzt für die anderen
parteien nicht mehr ausgeglichen werden
verlierer ist in jedem fall der wähler
und die künftige arbeitsfähigkeit des
bundestages denn das parlament dürfte
wenn überhaupt nur unwesentlich kleiner
werden möglicherweise sogar weiter
wachsen denn wenn die union bei der
nächsten wahl auch wieder
viele direktmandate holt aber bei den
zweitstimmen eher schwach abschneidet
dann kann der nächste bundestag auf über
800 abgeordnete anwachsen also gelöst
ist das problem noch nicht die
einschätzung unseres
hauptstadtkorrespondenten vielen dank
ihr call und jetzt der blick auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen im durchschnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage wurden
hierzulande täglich 1350 ansteckungen
neu gemeldet das ist derselbe wert wie
gestern in anderen europäischen ländern
geht die zahl der registrierten
neuinfektionen in den letzten wochen
noch steiler nach oben
ganz vorn spanien 6910 menschen haben
sich dort im schnitt der letzten sieben
tage angesteckt in frankreich sind es
4200 viel besser sieht es in italien aus
mit 930 dennoch sind auch hier die
menschen besorgt denn die bilder vom
anfang der krise haben alle noch im kopf
annette hilsenbeck auf den straßen roms
geht es allmählich wieder geschäftig zu
und trotzdem abstand halten ist angesagt
viele tragen hier auch im freien masken
was tagsüber gar nicht pflicht es die
italiener sind vorsichtig
ich mache mir sorgen natürlich wir haben
ja gesehen was in der vergangenheit
passiert
wir wollen ja wieder zurück zur
normalität unsere kinder wieder zur
schule
es sind diese bilder die die italiener
schreckten und disziplinieren armee
laster bringen ende märz in bergamo die
sage der avec die den corona virus zum
opfer gefallen sind weil zu viele
menschen sterben die kapazitäten nicht
reichen
doch auch in italien steigen die zahlen
langsam der neueste fall 61 jugendliche
in einer campinganlage mit dem corona
virus infiziert auf sardinien das seit
august zum hotspot geworden ist junge
menschen die unbekümmert feiern das
virus vergessen
der hauptgrund dass es auf einmal mehr
neu infizierte gibt alle total
verschwitzt alle wollen den musiker
sehen die von st italiens regierung
reagiert mit strenger seit zehn tagen
sind klubs und strandbars dicht ab sechs
uhr abends gilt im ganzen land dort
mussten pflicht im freien wo sich viele
menschen treffen
trotz ferien steigen die zahlen weniger
stark als in nachbarländern
es besteht natürlich ein starkes
bedürfnis nach normalität daher müssen
wir unsere botschaft weiterhin klar
formulieren und es jetzt so halten dass
das virus nicht unser system erfordert
denn am 15 september soll die schule
wieder starten italien weiß es braucht
dafür disziplin die zahl der
neuinfektionen darf nicht schnell
steigen ganz anderes thema jetzt dank
der weltweiten impfungen ist
kinderlähmung mittlerweile weitgehend
besiegt in deutschland gab es den
letzten polio fall 1990 und gestern
jubelte die weltgesundheitsorganisation
denn auch in afrika ist die krankheit
jetzt ausgerottet damit gibt es das
poliovirus offiziell nur noch in zwei
ländern in afghanistan und in pakistan
über die situation dort berichtet normen
odenthal die tropfen müssen rein und
runter irgendwie nur dann gibt es einen
bunten fingernagel der zeigt dieses kind
ist gegen polio geimpft das team zieht
von tür zu tür den pakistan hat
nachholbedarf polio will einfach nicht
verschwinden
hilft aber gerade jetzt ist das
schwierig corona ist für uns ein
riesiges problem die menschen fürchten
sich denken wir könnten sie mit dem
virus infizieren
sie lassen uns nicht in die häuser
lassen uns die kinder nicht impfen
aber das müssen wir müssen die kinder
schützen monatelang wurde nicht geimpft
alle konzentration lag auf corona und
schon steigen die polio fälle wieder an
die armut die fehlende hygiene das ist
der nährboden für kinderlähmung
pakistan und afghanistan sind die beiden
einzigen staaten wo polio nicht
ausgerottet ist oft sind es entlegene
gebiete wo die menschen schlecht
gebildet sind deren skepsis ist enorm
man muss viel aufklärungsarbeit leisten
für erfolgreiche impfkampagne
denn radikale religiöse propaganda hält
dagegen
der impfstoff sei teufelszeug vom westen
erfunden um muslime unfruchtbar zu
machen die mediziner müssen also
überzeugen dass sie nicht böses sondern
bestes wollen ich bin froh dass sie
jetzt wieder impfen wenn vor corona
können wir uns schützen wenn wir zu
hause bleiben aber polio ist doch vor
allem für unsere kinder viel schlimmer
krankheiten die irgendwie konkurrieren
dabei möchte man keine davon haben
niemand nirgendwo auf der welt in der us
stadt genauso sind bei neuen protesten
gegen rassismus und polizeigewalt zwei
menschen erschossen worden
wie es genau dazu kam es noch unklar
zuvor hatte es auseinandersetzungen
zwischen selbsternannten weißen milizen
und schwarzen gegeben
am sonntag hat ein polizist
einen schwarzen amerikaner in den rücken
geschossen und schwer verletzt
der rassismus die ausschreitungen und
straßenkämpfe spalten die usa und
dürften die präsidenten wahl in zehn
wochen beeinflussen
auf ihrem nominierungsparteitag schütten
die republikaner gestern vor allem
ängste vor einem sieg der demokraten
die first lady heute dagegen appellierte
an das gemeinschaftsgefühl aller
amerikaner sie werde ihre kostbare
redezeit nicht dazu gebrauchen die
andere seite anzugreifen
heike platz gehen das weiße haus als
kulisse showtime für die first lady die
am zweiten tag des parteitages der
republikaner für die wiederwahl ihres
mannes war nicht spalten sondern
versöhnen ihr motto den opfern der
pandemie drückte sie ihr mitgefühl aus
ich möchte dass ihr wisst dass ihr nicht
allein seit die regierung meines mannes
wird nicht aufhören zu kämpfen bis allen
eine wirksame behandlung und ein
impfstoff zur verfügung steht
melania der höhepunkt des abends ein
selbstloser staatsmann sei er immer
ehrlich auch wenn die ausgesprochenen
wahrheiten unangenehm sein zuschauern im
rose garden meist ohne maske zuvor
attackierten besonders trance kinder den
politischen gegner
ihr vater stünde für die schweigende
mehrheit des landes aus jerusalem
zugeschaltet der außenminister ein bruch
mit der langjährigen tradition sich als
staatsdiener politisch neutral zu
verhalten
was sie denkt hat china zur rechenschaft
gezogen dass es den china virus
vertuscht hat und zugelassen hat dass es
tot und wirtschaftliche zerstörung in
amerika und in der welt verbreitet auch
das ein novum der parteitag gegen korona
teilweise ins weiße haus verlagert die
macht des amtes der kampf ums weiße haus
kennt keine grenzen
der süden der usa bereitet sich derweil
auf die ankunft von hurrikan laura vor
mehr als 500.000 menschen in texas und
louisiana sollen sich in sicherheit
bringen bevor der sturm in der nacht auf
land trifft in haiti der dominikanischen
republik und auf kuba hatte laura zuvor
getötet mehr als 20 menschen kamen ums
leben
und auch hierzulande bläst ziemlicher
wind das sturmtief kirsten wirbelte
besonders in der nordhälfte deutschlands
bäume knickten um auch durch
herabfallende äste würden vereinzelt
menschen verletzt hier in kassel
entstand allerdings nur sachschaden
einige straßen und bahnstrecken mussten
gesperrt werden wie bei ennepetal in
nordrhein westfalen für wirbel im
fußball superstar lionel messi neuer der
wird tatsächlich wechseln was ja
eigentlich unvorstellbar weil das ist ja
eigentlich die erfolgreichste ehe im
weltfußball 20 jahre hat sie gehalten
mit 35 titel gewinnen aber in jüngster
zeit schwächelt basa das verhältnis zum
neuen trainer angespannt messi will die
scheidung der verein will um ihn kämpfen
foto shooting in barcelona trikot wenn
es nach leonel messi geht es diese zeit
vorbei der sportliche niedergang wohl
der hauptgrund exemplarisch das 2 2 8
gegen bayern in der champions league vor
knapp zwei wochen eine demütigung
zudem soll der neue trainer ronald
kuhlmann angeblich mitgeteilt haben dass
die zeit der privilegien vorbei sei
wasser ohne messi kollektives entsetzen
bei fans und medien
der verein will ihn halten und
umschmeichelt ihn
wir müssen messi großen respekt
entgegenbringen er ist der beste
fußballer der welt ist im wandel
aber es droht ein schmutziges ende messi
beruft sich auf eine ausstiegsklausel
die aber laut vor einem juni hätte
gezogen werden müssen
also bliebe es bei einer
festgeschriebenen ablösesumme von 700
millionen euro
es kann nicht sein dass der beste
spieler in der geschichte spaniens dass
er auf diese weise geht das alles vor
gericht zu ende geht so wie es im moment
aussieht das sind keine abmachung kann
das wäre dann das traurige finale einer
erfolgreichen beziehung und nochmal
barca auch in der frauen champions
league eine bittere niederlage gegen
eine deutsche mannschaft im halbfinale
gegen den vfl wolfsburg
lob gab es vom trainer für großem kampf
und leidenschaft wir haben es geschafft
natürlich heute mit sehr viel glück aber
wir freuen uns tierisch dass wir noch
mal die chance bekommen in einem finale
zu spielen
barcelona zwar mit den besseren chancen
arbeiten pech dieses handspiel von
kathrin hendrich blieb ungeahndet glück
für wolfsburg nach dem seitenwechsel die
szene des abends 58 minute fridolin gößl
mit dem 10
barcelona liess sich davon aber nicht
beeindrucken kämpfte weiter allein es
fehlte das glück
wolfsburg trifft im finale entweder auf
paris asamoah oder titelverteidiger
zum tennis da hatte jan lennard struff
beim von cincinnati nach new york
verlegten masters turnier überraschend
das viertelfinale erreicht
der 30 jahre alte warsteiner gewann
gegen den weltranglistenzehnten david
hofer aus belgien mit 6 4 3 6 und 6 4
und trifft nun auf den weltranglisten
ersten novak djokovic
das war es von mir jetzt kommt noch
lotto die gewinnzahlen lauten 3 15 18 26
39 40 superzahl 3 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
der sturm ist noch nicht vorüber sagt
unser metrologie century mehr dazu
gleich bei ihm beim wetter christian
sievers begrüßt sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen abend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter da sie ist
christin und kirsten ist ein sturmtief
ist noch nicht durch wird allmählich
sich weiter nach osten bewegen und in
der nacht gibt es im osten deutschlands
weitere sturmböen in der zweiten
nachthälfte lässt das allmählich nach
aber mit schauern und gewittern müssen
sie noch rechnen ansonsten ist es
trocken die temperaturen sinken auf neun
bis zehn grad im südwesten
über bis richtung saarland ansonsten ist
es milder zwischen 14 und 16 grad in den
östlichen landesteilen morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es noch stürmische
böen im osten deutschlands dazu noch
einige schauer die lassen allmählich
nach im westen von den kompakten worten
fallen durchaus mal einige tropfen
heraus ansonsten gibt es sonnige
abschnitte im süden deutschlands bei
werten bis 25 grad am oberrhein 23 im
rhein main gebiet und entlang der küsten
18 bis 19 grad die kommenden tage
bringen schauer und gewitter zum
beispiel am freitag im süden und im
westen 18 bis 25 grad die höchsten werte
und danach wird es ein wenig kühler aber
weitere schauer sind dabei damit ein
schöner abend